[Music]
okay everybody I am so excited today
because I am joined by Lucy Hale for the
first time and returning to the show is
Kunal Nair how you guys doing today good
man good to see you again nice to meet
you nice to meet you and good to see you
again
um I absolutely love this film I'm
really excited about it AJ Vickery is
the lead character played by Kunal so
Kunal my first question is for you
what's the process like for a heavy
emotional role like this like are you
ever going full method like you spending
extra hours in the bookstore like how's
that go about well no I wish I could
have said that uh no I mean look I think
we all have a different processes as an
actor it doesn't necessarily matter what
your process is as long as you're
truthful when the camera is rolling you
know
um but for me it was really enjoyable to
kind of just Place someone who's kind of
lives in this world it was kind of
enjoyable I didn't miss necessarily have
to always be nice and kind and you know
I could be a little curmoginy as they
say and it was a great uh experience for
me in self-expression to find different
aspects of my own personality yeah I
love that I love the different areas of
emotions you explore in this character
you do a great job doing it now Lucy
you've played so many great roles what
excites you the most and stood out to
you the most about Amelia
I mean I think when I
originally read the scripts
um I knew Kunal was attached to it but
it's so rare for me to be as moved as I
was and um I think that you know there's
so many movies out there that are about
you know bigger is better and explosions
and creatures and this was like the
opposite of that and it was
not simple because there are so many
different layers of the characters but
it was really was about love and loss
and grief and Second Chances and all at
the heart of a bookstore like which
these things just bookstores are a Dying
Breed and
um and I my character Amelia
who plays a book sales rep who meets AJ
and ends up falling in love with AJ
um she represented hope and light and um
and
you know she sort of woven into the
story and sorry my dog is being crazy
right now
and I'm like he's losing that uh
represents hope and light and I just
think these kind of stories are the ones
I want to tell and be a part of and we
need more of that and I I think that
watching the movie it'll make you want
to pick up a book and it'll make you
hopefully feel
um like you have faith in humanity a
little bit a little bit yeah yeah I love
that answer and I love you saying that
Hope and Faith it brings and also the
how relatable it is like to today it's
not like so over the top I really like
that and Kunal I'm gonna put you on the
spot here what was your favorite thing
about Lucy as a scene partner
oh that's a great question I think that
you know
um
you always hope in a scene partner that
they're listening and I know it sounds
like a very simple thing it does and
actors always say well you've got to
listen to be a good actor but truthfully
even some of the greatest actors don't
really listen when you're in scenes with
them and Lucy was always there with you
no matter what happens in a scene and
when you have that kind of trust in an
actor opposite you you really can do
your best work
yeah that's that's amazing
um to hear that too and that's so true
about listening and perhaps you Lucy for
being like that and Lucy you had
mentioned too about the bookstores kind
of like dying out but I'm curious when
you read are you a supporter of reading
the hard copy book still are you in this
Kindle movement what's your like take
can I tell my favorite thing about Kunal
you can also skip that question and say
that it's this it's the same thing it is
rare to find someone I'm like oh you're
here with me you are looking in my eyes
and you're following my every move but I
think this character can could have
easily gone down a dark hole where
you're like oh God I want to turn this
off but there's something about Kunal
that is so disarming and relatable and
he's FL the characters flawed but you're
you just really captured what it is to
be human in a very uplifting way and I
just I don't have enough nice things to
say about Kunal you're just a dream
um okay yes I am a fan of books as well
I will not get a Kindle I will not read
anything online like I gotta go to the
bookstore I have to I have to re I'll be
in for hours and I have to physically
read and turn the page and there's
something so satisfying about closing it
and putting it on your bookshelf when
you're done I'll always be that way I
think that thank you and that was
amazing that you're able to sneak both
answers in I love that very cool
um Everybody watch Lucy and Kunal kill
it in the story life of AJ fickory which
is in theaters Friday they both do
amazing work and it's awesome to see how
close they are and how great that comes
and translates onto the screen thank you
guys so much for joining me and we'll
talk to you in the future one day thanks
dude thank you